how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel we have some
major phase 5 news today as Captain
Marvel 2 is officially in a
pre-production this is super exciting
news for those of you who enjoyed the
first Captain Marvel film and even if
you didn't enjoy it you may enjoy the
second one because it seems like Marvel
has some pretty big and pretty
interesting ideas for the sequel and
these ideas could possibly be the
inclusion of spider-man and the Scarlet
Witch in the film not to mention a
Secret Invasion storyline and not to
mention the biggest of them all the
beginning of the Assembly of the New
Avengers so we'll break down everything
that has currently been reported about
Captain Marvel 2 and the rumors going
around as well if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe I'm giving
away an Xbox one or ps4 when I hit 550
thousand subscribers so today we have
news about a sequel to Marvel's billion
dollar grossing film Captain Marvel
despite how you felt about Captain
Marvel it was truly a box-office success
and of course we knew that Marvel was
planning a sequel they'd be dumb not to
and Kevin Feige also mentioned this at
San Diego comic-con however it appears
that they're going to be taking a
different direction with Captain Marvel
2 according to a report yesterday from
The Hollywood Reporter Marvel is going
with a new writer for the sequel right
now as it stands for Captain Marvel to
Marvel actually took a rider from the
wann division series to write the script
for Captain Marvel 2 and that right
there alone is enough to say that this
film is probably going to be pretty
different but along with Marvel getting
a new writer for Captain Marvel to The
Hollywood Reporter also said that
they're going to be bringing the film
from the 1990s to the present time after
the events of Avengers in game and this
makes perfect sense if you consider the
post-credits scene for spider-man far
from home spoiler alert if you somehow
haven't seen it yet but in the
post-credits scene a far from home we
saw that Nick Fury and Maria Hill the
whole entire time have been scroll and
we also discovered that Nick Fury has
been building sword and Captain Marvel
and spider-man are connected through
this post-credit scene now we know that
Captain Marvel and Nick Fury are pretty
much BFFs and we know that in the next
spider-man peter is going to be wanted
but he's probably going to turn to Nick
Fury for help after all it seems very
likely that Nick Fury could help him but
this is said to bring
captain marvel and spider-man together
if you recall when Sony and Marvel
worked out a new deal it was for one
more solo film and a team-up film and
that team-up film is widely believed to
be Captain Marvel to Peter is supposedly
said to have a crush on Captain Marvel
after the events of Avengers endgame and
now it appears as if they are going to
be working together during Captain
Marvel too for a Secret Invasion
storyline now the normal Secret Invasion
storyline from the comics is where the
scroll invade earth and shape-shift and
two other Avengers it gets to the point
where even the Avengers don't know who
is real but Captain Marvel went a
different route when the movie was
released the scroll were revealed to be
good however this does not mean that all
scroll are good in fact there are most
likely evil scroll out there not to
mention the Kree are still out there as
well and some of them can look like
perfectly normal human beings so it
appears that the new Secret Invasion
storyline that we're going to get if
Marvel decides to go that way is going
to be with the Kree and still with the
scroll the scroll of the ability to
infiltrate earth and go undetected we
saw this and spider-man far from home
and according to old rumors that were
circulating around about Captain Marvel
to Peter Parker and Captain Marvel are
going to have to team up together to
fight some of them and since they got
one of the writers from the wan division
series it is very possible that they can
include the Scarlet Witch as well
especially if they are planning this to
be a team-up movie because if you think
of the New Avengers these are going to
be the core spider-man Captain Marvel
and the Scarlet Witch we've lost pretty
much the main Avengers and we don't
really know what the Hulk is going to be
up to and it's even been said by Marvel
that Captain Marvel and spider-man are
going to go on to lead the Avengers so
it seems like Captain Marvel too could
be the start of assembling the team of
the New Avengers
Rodie slash war machine could even get
involved as well as in the comics him
and Captain Marvel do you have a
relationship together and an Avengers
end game there was a small tiny moment
where it did look like Rhodey and
Captain Marvel could have a small thing
together Kevin Feige has already
confirmed that he does in fact know who
the new Avengers team is going to be and
of course he knows Marvel said that they
already have phase 5 complete so he
already knows the next five years of the
MCU and even though it's been said that
we're not going to get another Avengers
film for a long time they're going to
start to assemble the team and it looks
like the start of the
is going to be in Captain Marvel - so
exciting news today an official phase 5
movie has begun pre-production a movie
that is hopefully and reportedly going
to start to set up the New Avengers and
the MCU let me know what you think about
this let me know what you think about
Captain Marvel spider-man and the
Scarlet Witch teaming up would you like
to see that I think it would be awesome
let me know down below in the comments
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe when notifications turned on
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU don't forget to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
we'll fluff